all right ladies and gentlemen let's
talk about this uh this story because
this is this is getting to me man
uh first the first store we have is from
the verge youtube has removed steven
crowder from its partner program
indefinitely
they say he'll be back in a week but
without youtube ad revenue
why no seriously when you get a strike
on youtube you don't get removed from
the partner program
you just get told hey you got a strike
you can't upload for a week you can't
live stream
why did they remove him from the partner
program to take away his revenue
see that is not legitimate in my opinion
and i don't know if you know crowder
would agree with me or if he's gonna
appreciate it
they're they're they're just trying to
remove him and they're gonna find any
reason
and we got more stores i'm trying to go
through these quickly the verge says
two weeks ago after youtube revealed its
definition of
hate speech was so narrow that it
couldn't remove a wildly racist tirade
for being wildly racist
what is this the verge is this an
opinion piece or is this fact-based news
you see this is the problem with media
that's why channels like crowders are
important so shows like ours are
important
they're giving you their opinion as the
opener because they don't report the
news they never did
they say we wondered out loud what it
would take for you to stop promoting
conservative commentator
stephen crowder as an official youtube
partner and allowing him to profit from
those tirades notice
they just say conservative that's it
ladies and gentlemen they're not saying
far right anymore the the overton window
is shifting but it's very interesting
they no longer need to say you're far
right you're getting banned now it's
just
he's a conservative they should remove
them from the partner program that's it
they say today we have a partial answer
youtube has officially suspended stephen
crowder's main channel from youtube's
partner program indefinitely
which includes removing his ability to
run ads it's also banning him from
uploading videos for a full week
after his latest infraction a now
removed video
that reportedly challenged the
legitimacy of the vote in nevada
youtube has a policy against false
claims the election was stolen full stop
lies or misframing say the least the
policy that youtube has as it was
explained to me
by youtube is that two criteria must be
met
you must say something specific about
the election
and you must say something specific
about donald trump together
crowder did a video where he
investigated voter addresses
and sent people people to those
locations in those videos he never says
anything about the overall implications
of the election
and even said in an update video he
couldn't anyway he doesn't have the
evidence in fact
he even pushed back on mike lindell
saying mike lindell's claims about
dominion are wrong someone gave him
wrong information so what youtube is
claiming about what crowder did
is illegitimate and and even if it was
true that he did one video where he said
this
why take him out of the partner program
now here's where it gets absolutely
insane
crowder put up a video explaining what
was going on
he put it on instagram and he put it on
his other youtube channel crowder bits
because he's got like 855 000
subscribers there
youtube took that video down and issued
a warning saying that he was
circum trying to circumvent his ban all
right i'm gonna break something down for
everybody i know
i'm i'm going out we got people here to
hang out and talk but i've got to
explain all this
i had a conversation you may know this
we had alex jones on the show
alex jones said something a lot of
people mis misheard what he said
including myself
and it didn't matter youtube didn't care
they said well it was bad enough
and they removed that episode with alex
jones and michael malus from this
channel
issued a warning and i talked to them on
the phone for quite some time and they
refused to reinstate it i said we could
take out that little tiny
one second snippet we could take it out
maybe put it back up and they said
no and i said okay i'm gonna have him
back on the show then
we're gonna do it again and we did and i
said
in the event you guys give me a strike
what does that mean for my other
channels
and i was told by youtube so long as the
content
is different from what you do on these
channels
it is fine and i said okay tim cast irl
is a conversational show with guests
where we go over news stories
my other channels are me and my personal
rants and monologues
is that substantially different and i
was told yes
they're not the same thing they're
different channels for a reason and i
said okay
well that means that's what i want to
know because if you give me a strike on
this channel
i can still keep producing on my other
channels right then i'm willing to take
that risk
we're going to have them back on the
show and we did and it did well because
i'm not going to
a lot of people were like oh tim is
giving up in censorship i'm like no as
soon as they did it i was like
i called him right back and said guys
come back on the show we're not doing
this
now what they're doing with crowder
crowder does a show
on his main channel that's produced
there's multiple people involved there's
microphones they're sitting in chairs
and they have cameras and he's sitting
at a desk and he's wearing his you know
he's out for the show he's got his
holster on and all that stuff
it is it is produced and set up on
crowder bits
he filmed a video on his cell phone
explaining what was going on
content that was 100 substantially
different
from his produced show they took that
video down and gave him a warning that
means he does it again
they're gonna give him a strike that is
illegitimate
youtube is not issuing legitimate
strikes against
or or warnings or whatever against
crowder 100
and i have a i have a feeling it has
something to do
with media matters because they put out
this story where they said after being
suspended from youtube stephen crowder
announces his plan to evade it
via his other youtube channel i'm not
going to go into great details but i'm
going to vaguely mention something very
interesting that's been going on
that was going on for some time we had a
video that media matters targeted
and made false claims about for some
reason that video got demonetized
so i contacted contacted youtube and i
said why is this video demonetized and
they said
seems to be an error don't worry we will
monetize it for you
and they did and then there was an
update i guess on this media matters
piece and then all of a sudden i noticed
the video was demonetized again
and then i reached back out to google
and said oop that's strange we'll fix it
again
it happened twice there was a back and
forth somebody at these activist
organizations knows people at google or
youtube and they go in and they're
screwing with channels
so when i see youtube say oh stephen
crowder broke the rule he didn't
actually break
because they laid it out for me they
sent everyone an email
youtube sent me an email said here's the
specific criteria you would have to say
in order to get a strike on your channel
crowder never broke those rules
so you know what you're telling us
youtube that there's literally nothing
we can do
if you want to take us down you will lie
and you will do it and then what we see
from all these news organizations
they say well crowder was taken down
because he violated the policy where he
claimed x y and z
they claim that because youtube said the
policy was violated
that affirms that crowder did something
wrong he did not
if youtube tells me you can't you can't
drink bottled water on your show
and then i say okay i won't and then
they give me a strike anyway claiming i
did
the medial report tim poole got taken
down for drinking bottled water on his
show even if i didn't
that's what they're doing it's only a
matter of time and
i tell you this people are saying oh
tim's two miles he's not gonna get
censored he's not gonna get banned or
whatever
we had alex jones and michael mouse on
the show and they took it down and i
immediately called them and brought them
back because i'm not going to bend the
knee to
lies and manipulations and just
unreasonable
actions unprofessional behavior from
from from youtube
if you get a problem with something one
of my guests says and i offer to snip
that out
that is me going well above and beyond
my own principles
because i think we should be able to
have that conversation up as it is but
i'm willing to recognize youtube has
this platform
and i say okay what's what's the best
thing we can do to make sure 99.99
of this gets out fine i'll obey that
rule but i'm going to launch timcast.com
and we're going to talk about what we
want to talk behind
this members only paywall to protect
ourselves from for in the event youtube
does take us down
facebook removed me from the
monetization program for simply covering
the news stephen crowder is suspended
for a week and removed from the partner
program
for simply sending out reporters to
track claims about voter regularity that
was it
he did not make any claims and now here
we are
rant over i suppose no it's
it's a necessary rant you know i would
love to know
who is on who is receiving the same
wrath from youtube
on the other side of the spectrum right
i mean there have been amazing
allegations for four years about
president trump as a as a puppet of of
vladimir putin right there there have
been out and out lies
from what we would consider quote
unquote the left is there any
leftist group as big as stephen crowder
who has been kicked off the platform for
these types of
violations of service no only small
progressives have been banned
there have been many of them smaller
channels and they shouldn't have been
banned either
i 100 defend the right of all of the
socialists democratic socialists
progressives communists who produce on
youtube
and i've seen some of the channels that
got removed on the left and i don't see
a legit legitimate reason as to why they
were banned
it seems like what youtube is trying to
do is create a mono culture
they're trying to force everyone into a
i don't want to say center left i don't
necessarily want to say far left
homogenous
a homogeneous establishment democrat
left position getting rid of crowder is
an assassin
is necessary for them to pull off
something like that and i tell you i'm
not
i'm not big into conspiracies but they
just came out
and made claims about why they removed
crowder's content and i
actually having privy information
speaking to google know
they are these statements are just not
true the claims made against them
not true here we go i'd like to add i so
you know i built mines i was one of the
founder co-founders of mines and i
helped design
and construct the website real quick for
those that aren't familiar minds
is another social media platform it's
got it can host videos you can post
things
so i had to ethically build out the
terms of service like how are we gonna
how are we gonna adjudicate
user violations of our terms basically
and i was an administrator and
what i realized pretty early on is you
don't ban people
you ban the channel if the channel is in
violation
assume nothing about the people because
that person can make another channel and
if that new channel doesn't violate you
don't mess with it
so that them going after steve is
effed it's messed up you don't target
individuals that makes no sense
your terms specifically target channels
not people
so the thought that he would make
another channel and do something that
doesn't violate terms and still get it
taken down is insane to me
this is why i'm saying they're targeting
him and his business because
as i stated the rules are if you have
two channels i'll try to make this clear
you have two channels and one of them
is videos about dogs and one of those
videos about cats and your videos about
dogs gets take it's it's a strike
because a dog you know understood a butt
or something like oh yeah it's
it's inappropriate and you put up a
video about a cat that's supposed to be
allowed
because it's a different form of content
if crowder uploads something that's not
his show
he's not commenting on the news he's
simply saying hey guys here's an update
as to what's going on
they are screwing with him that's it
they're they're
they're they're targeting him it's
unfair and i'm sick of the butt my
private business
argument from all of these establishment
crony types it's just not the case
we need balance and we need
representation for
people of different ideas different
ideologies and different perspectives
if they get rid of crowder crowders fans
don't go away
they get angry they go other places so
you know what in that regard maybe
youtube will absolutely [ __ ] itself
by doing this
but the problem is that alphabet
google subsidizes youtube so that
other video platforms can't be as
successful
and that keeps a stranglehold on the
market for channels like like minor
everyone else's but more importantly
youtube is first in best dressed
and the biggest the second biggest
search engine i believe in the world
and it is used by everybody we ask only
that those rules be applied fairly
and that the contracts they have people
sign are upheld so i wonder this
if youtube says you must abide by our
community guidelines otherwise we can
ban you
but then they they ban you or strike you
even though you didn't violate those
guidelines i wonder if they're in breach
of their own terms on their
end i wonder if there's a possibility
that you could go after them because we
have seen strategies like this before
i don't know exactly what crowd around
will end up doing i know that his
uh half asian lawyer bill made an
announcement about you know what's
happening the blaze posted it
and for those you know i want to make
sure i give a shout out to crowder the
best of my ability
they say you can go to
louderwithcrowder.com what is it
lotterycrotter.com
mug club or just go to lotter with
crowdersweb.com go to his website
and if you want to support him as well
if youtube
is going after a crowd in such a way
that is illegitimate
do you really think a channel like this
can last much longer after they they
take him down
these it's it's it's the canary in the
coal mine for everybody the way i
explained it a long time ago was
we're standing on this big island these
with cliffs all around
and the waves are just crashing and
eroding at the at one side
sure the far right gets banned this is
what they do that's what authoritarians
do say oh nobody likes the far right
fringe weirdo racist and conspiracy
theorists so when they get banned the
establishment types are like i don't
care
then they come for very staunch hardcore
pro-america conservatives
and even regular conservatives are
pointing out like hey that's bad
regular people are going like well i'm
not a fan of those those kind of people
and the left ignores it now they're
coming for regular run-of-the-mill
high-profile mainstream conservative
types people like steven crowder
what's next moderates yeah and then
we're then we're gone i'm
i'm pretty critical of google i have
been since they bought youtube 2007. i
was freaking out i was a youtuber 2006.7
i was like oh well
google's bought about to buy youtube
it's going to get super corporate
and we'll see and google whoever's
running google you guys do an amazing
job
at search algorithms i love your search
your search engine but
i don't think you guys are equipped to
run a social network
you had youtube in 2007 you screwed it
up and then you built google plus which
nobody used when you could have been
using youtube as your social network
that's right
and they got rid of video responses
which was one of the hottest community
building
pieces of tech on the on the website and
and they
they make these heavy-handed it's just a
huge company
i'm not i i don't know i can't get too
critical because i don't work there i
never have
um but it just it saddens me that you
would drag your social network through
the mud like this when you have an
opportunity to build the best one
it's a it's a growing cult infection
it's a cult
there's i was trying to find i know
there were a bunch of google execs i
wasn't i was listening clearly
but i was trying to google the uh trying
to google a whole bunch of google execs
who went to the biden administration
trying to find names
but the stories that i'm i'm finding in
this search are all about how
the bite administration will be tougher
on big tech than than the previous
administration
um none of them will well you know i
mean these are questions
we'd like to have legitimate hearings on
this right we've talked about it before
they every now and then get hauled up in
front of congress and
um zuckerberg is there right with his
really pasty face you know
um and just an awful usually an awful
camera angle which is kind of bizarre
that
no one does a good job on his on his
yeah you know like like framing your
shot a little bit but you got 60 billion
dollars
but it would be curious to get some of
these folks involved to say what is the
how much further does the big tax
censorship get to go before it becomes
like a true just violation of of of
civil liberties of
the constitution we've already seen it
egregiously yep but how much more
they have had so many hearings i i just
don't care anymore they just lie
they lie absolutely i used to watch them
i was like this is really exciting
you know ted cruz is gonna grill jack
dorsey it's gonna be fantastic
and now it's like oh it's the fifth time
huh it's a rerun you know what i mean at
this point i'm not interested in
watching that's a waste of time not
doing anything
uh free i mean i'm obsessed with freeing
the software code of large social
networks if a network starts getting
massive traffic
like becomes part of the commons 100
million hit users a month i don't know
some arbitrary number but you free their
software code of the
of the social network aspect so that you
can other people can build that same
network
tech other than that i'm always at a
loss of how do they
that's why i don't think they have done
anything about it because if you break
up facebook into multiple
companies and i talked about this last
week like instagram facebook messenger
facebook prime and then zuck
owns the same percentage of all these
new companies
nothing's changed he still commands the
terms of service of all the new
companies he still owns them all
so you can't break it move them so yeah
but can you i don't think you can
legally do that so what's the real risk
then that people looking for
internet freedom end up on tick tock
which is owned by the communist chinese
oh and there's less there right i mean
it's gonna get it's gonna be
worse you know we need decentralized
social media i suppose
yeah we need i don't necessarily think
the blockchain is the answer but i do
think there's great
prospects in in blockchain technology
but we just need and something we've
talked about the show quite a bit is
you know i'm talking about creating an
open source plug-in that people can put
on their websites that just networks
websites together
so no one could ban anybody and there's
something called the fetaverse we talk
about a lot which is
it's like a protocol instead of a
website where you can follow someone
from a different you can follow like
john john.com or whatever instead of
instead of following at john you follow
john john.com and you can follow
johnnethgab.com and get all of their
feeds showing up like twitter or other
social media
there's um other than blockchain there's
like r weave which i think mines is
looking into
right now bill has been and like ipfs
interplanetary file system and they they
tend to be faster than the blockchain
for stuff like this sometimes so they're
advancing this this decentralized tech
and i think we'll eventually have
something that can host videos thanks
for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time